schwarze löcher sind die wahrscheinlich
faszinierendsten phänomene in unserem
universum
sie werfen unglaublich viele fragen auf
die wir noch keine antworten haben aber
sie helfen uns auch unsere welt besser
zu verstehen und es gibt einige fakten
über schwarze löcher die einfach nur
verdammt cool sind
kein wunder also dass ihr eigentlich
seit dieser kanal besteht ein video über
schwarze löcher sehen wollte
und hier ist es endlich wenn ihr also
bereits seite dann geht es jetzt los wir
bauen uns heute unser eigenes schwarzes
loch
um ein schwarzes loch zu erzeugen
braucht man eigentlich nur einen simplen
grund stoff masse jede form von materie
kann zu einem schwarzen loch werden
unsere sonne die erde sogar du und ich
alles was man dafür tun muss ist die
masse zu komprimieren
man muss sie so stark zusammenpressen
dass sie auf einen winzig kleinen raum
passt wie klein um das zu verstehen
hilft es sich unsere erde anzuschauen
oder um genau zu sein wie man diese
verletzt wenn man heutzutage
standardmäßig von unserem blauen
planeten ins all fliegen möchte springt
man in die nächste rakete und wird hoch
geschossen
nur dass man nicht wirklich hoch
geschossen wird sondern eher hoch
gedrückt die raketen bußler bauern
während des fluges ja die ganze zeit
durch
aber wie schnell müsste man sein wenn
man auf der oberfläche der erde mit
einem katapult in die luft geschossen
wird und nicht nur auf die erde zurück
fallen will ich erspare ich das rechnen
es sind genau elf 1200 meter pro sekunde
oder zumindest wenn man viele dinge wie
die erdrotation und den luftwiderstand
vernachlässigt das ist die sogenannte
flucht geschwindigkeit der erde
und weil so viele dinge dabei außer acht
gelassen werden ist die formel für diese
zahl auch recht simpel die massereicher
ein objekt ist und die kleiner sein
radius ist desto größer muss die
geschwindigkeit sein um diesem objekt zu
entkommen
ein schwarzes loch wird dadurch
definiert dass seine flucht
geschwindigkeit größer ist als die
lichtgeschwindigkeit
das bedeutet im klartext dass man
schneller als licht sein müsste und von
der oberfläche eines schwarzen lochs in
einem schub zu entkommen
mit anderen worten es ist wegen
einsteins relativitätstheorie nicht
möglich wenn eine masse also so stark
komprimiert wird dass sie diesen radius
den sogenannten schwarz schild radios
unterschreitet dann wird sie zu einem
schwarzen loch
und um das zu bewerkstelligen braucht
man eine menge energie würde man zum
beispiel die sonne in ein schwarzes loch
verwandeln wollen müsste man sie auf 0 6
kilometer zusammenpressen und um unsere
erde in ein schwarzes loch zu verwandeln
müsste man sie auf eine kugel
komprimieren die kleiner ist als ein
zentimeter
schaut euch mal um geht nach draußen und
stellt euch vor dass das alles in einer
murmel platz findet in unserem universum
haben nur wenige dinge die energie um so
viel masse zu komprimieren
aber eine supernova gehört dazu wenn ein
stern am ende seiner lebenszeit ist gibt
es einen kritischen punkt wird dieser
überschritten dann implodiert der sterne
in einer riesigen supernova dabei wird
die masse des sterns mit einer
unglaublichen geschwindigkeit ins
zentrum des sterns gezogen bis zu einem
viertel der lichtgeschwindigkeit kann
dabei erreicht werden der ganze vorgang
dauert nur einen bruchteil einer sekunde
was dann entsteht ist entweder ein
neutronenstern oder wenn der stern groß
genug war ein schwarzes loch
unsere sonne ist zu klein als dass auf
sie ein schwarzes loch entstehen könnte
dafür müsste sie ungefähr 20 mal so groß
sein aber stellen uns trotzdem einmal
vor dass unsere sonne heute durch ein
schwarzes loch ersetzt werden würde
was würde sich für uns ändern nun
erstaunlicherweise recht wenig viele
denken dass schwarze löcher alles um
sich herum einsaugen wie ein riesiger
tödlicher weltraum staubsauger aber das
stimmt zu einem gewissen teil ein
schwarzes loch die dinge an wie die erde
dinge anzieht mit gravitation ein
schwarzes loch das unsere sonne ersetzt
würde für uns keinen unterschied machen
solange es die selbe masse hat wie
unsere sonne
außerhalb naja dass wir alle erfrieren
würden aber an und für sich ist es kein
problem in der nähe oder sogar eine
umlaufbahn eines schwarzen lochs zu sein
und wie würde das für uns aussehen na ja
ziemlich schwarz die tatsache dass
schwarze löcher so klein sind und dass
nichts nicht einmal licht ihnen
entweichen kann sorgt dafür dass sie
quasi unsichtbar sind
tatsächlich konnte noch nie ein foto von
einem schwarzen loch gemacht werden
alles was ihr jemals über schwarze
löcher gesehen habt war entweder eine
computersimulation oder ein bild eines
künstlers aber das soll sich 2017 ändern
wenn wissenschaftler das erste mal ein
foto von einem schwarzen loch machen
wollen das event horizon telescope
verbindet weltweit über neun teleskope
wie somit als ein einziges riesiges
teleskop fungieren und dieses soll dann
auch das supermassereiche schwarze loch
im zentrum der milchstraße gerichtet
werden und obwohl dieses schwarze loch
die masse von über vier milliarden
sonnen hat ist es mit der größe von nur
30 sonnen recht klein
der versuch aus unserer entfernung ein
foto davon zu schießen ist in etwa so
als wolle man eine cd auf dem mond
fotografieren aber auch wenn dieser
versuch ist es ja eine große sache ist
und uns viel über einsteins
relativitätstheorie und unsere raumzeit
sagen kann
solltet ihr nicht zu viel von diesem
foto erwarten wie gesagt nicht einmal
licht kann einem schwarzen loch
entkommen was ihr also
höchstwahrscheinlich sehen werdet ist
ein schwarzer punkt mit etwas gas
drumherum
aber warum ist das eigentlich so klar
die gravitation eines schwarzen lochs
ist so stark dass die flucht
geschwindigkeit größer ist als die
lichtgeschwindigkeit bedeutet es kann
nicht entkommen
aber das stimmt so eigentlich gar nicht
denkt dran eine rakete kann der
gravitation der erde auch entkommen ohne
11.200 meter pro sekunde zu fliegen
die flucht geschwindigkeit beschreibt
die geschwindigkeit die etwas haben muss
um sich von der oberfläche weg
katapultieren zu können also ohne
während des flugs weiter schub zu
generieren wie zum beispiel eine rakete
tun würde
der wahre grund warum aus einem
schwarzen loch nichts mehr rauskommen
kann ist dass es gar keinen draußen mehr
gibt ganz genau
sobald ihr in einem schwarzen loch seit
gibt es nur noch eine richtung nach
innen hin zur singularität aber wie ist
das möglich kann man sich nicht einfach
oben drehen und wieder nach draußen
gucken
das ist eine super spannende frage also
probieren sie es einfach aus
wagen wir den sprung in ein schwarzes
loch augen zu und durch
wobei macht vielleicht besser nicht die
augen zu denn das was ihr bei diesem
sprung sehen könnt wird alles
übersteigen was ihr jemals zuvor gesehen
habt und spoiler alert es wird auch das
letzte sein was sie jemals sehen werde
die erste grenze die wir auf unserem weg
zum schwarzen loch erreichen ist die
photonen sphäre das ist der abstand zum
schwarzen loch auf der photonen in einem
stabilen orbit unser schwarze loch herum
fliegen können das klingt nicht nur
total cool das ist es auch denn das was
unter anderem bedeutet ist dass ihr
theoretisch euren eigenen hinterkopf
sehen können das licht wird von eurem
hinterkopf reflektiert und anstatt
normal geradeaus wegzufliegen wird es
von einem schwarzen loch in eine
kreisbahn gezwungen bis es einmal
rundherum geflogen ist und in eure augen
fällt und hier sollte ich das prinzip
mit den richtungen noch einmal erklären
denn viele von euch sind gerade bestimmt
aufgesprungen und schreiben das photon
keine masse haben und dass sie von
gravitation nicht beeinflusst werden
und das stimmt auch zumindest der erste
teil photonen besitzen keine masse
allerdings beeinflusst gravitation auch
nicht masse sondern unsere raumzeit
gravitation ist nur eine krümmung
unserer vier dem uns in einen raum
zweiten wenn ein photonen also an einem
schwarzen loch vorbei fliegt dann
verfolgt ist eigentlich die linien der
gekrümmten raumzeit aus der perspektive
des photons fliegt es weiterhin
geradeaus nur ist eben der raum um das
photon herum so stark gekrümmt dass
dieses im kreis fliegt wenn man dieses
konzept erst einmal verstanden und
akzeptiert hat dann versteht man
schwarze löcher auch direkt viel besser
die nächste grenze auf unserer reise ist
der ereignishorizont und das ist der
punkt an dem man sich absolut sicher
sein sollte dass man die ganze aktion
durchziehen will
denn sobald man hinter dem
ereignishorizont ist gibt es keine
möglichkeiten mehr zurückzukommen kein
seil keine kraft nichts kann einem
helfen keine kraft die der physik
heutzutage bekannte zumindest denn
hinter dem ereignishorizont gibt es
physikalisch gesehen nur noch eine
richtung die unglaubliche
gravitationskraft des schwarzen lochs
hat die raumzeit so sehr gekrümmt dass
jede richtung zur singularität hin zeigt
und wenn euch das noch nicht komisch
vorkam
dann wird es jetzt richtig verrückt das
universum wird immer kleiner bis es zu
einem kleinen hellen punkt über unseren
kopf wird denn auch das licht der
umliegenden sterne kann nur in den
trichter fallen wo es dann wie in eine
rutsche auf dich drauf fällt deswegen
ist das komplette universum jetzt über
dir was irgendwie lustig ist wenn man
mal darüber nachdenkt und unter dir
siehst du nichts
gähnende leere denn setzt licht das von
objekten wieder nach oben reflektiert
wird wird schnell durch die gekrümmte
raum zeit wieder zurück in schwarze loch
umgeleitet irgendwann siehst du nicht
einmal mehr deine füße oder dein körper
du kannst nur noch nach oben gucken wo
du das universum in einem punkt vereint
siehst und hier gibt es ein weiteres
missverständnis
viele denken dass man jetzt wegen der
starken gravitation die zukunft sehen
kann
die zukunft des gesamten universums die
sich vor deinen augen abspielt dieser
gedanke wird unter anderem durch den
film interstellar gestürzt aber hier ist
das ding und es ist krass ich das sage
aber der hollywoodfilm hat recht in der
nähe von starker gravitation vergeht die
zeit von außen betrachtet langsamer was
bedeutet dass man in der nähe eines
schwarzen lochs in die zukunft heißt
aber das gilt nur wenn man sich den
gravitation quasi widersetzt in
interstellar sind unsere protagonisten
auf einem planeten während dieser um ein
schwarzes loch kreis
trotz der starken anziehungskraft
bleiben sie aber im orbit um das
schwarze loch und somit im gleichen
abstand zu diesem und das ist wichtig
der boden des planeten beschleunigt sie
quasi vom schwarzen loch weg und das
sorgt für die sogenannte zeit der nation
also die zeitreise wenn man so will
feldmann aber in ein schwarzes loch
müsste man sich von diesem weg
beschleunigen um langsamer zu altern und
die welt um sich herum schneller
wahrzunehmen
man könnte sich ein seil vorstellen mit
dem man knapp über dem ereignishorizont
gehalten wird allerdings könnte man sich
auch genauso gut auf einen
neutronenstern stellen die
gravitationskräfte während so stark dass
sie einzelne moleküle von dir
auseinander erreichen würden und das ist
übrigens auch das was als nächstes in
unserer reise passiert
nachdem wir den ereignishorizont
überschritten haben was aus unserer
perspektive wahrscheinlich recht
unspektakulär aussieht gibt es spaghetti
ja ihr habt richtig gehört in einem
schwarzen loch gibt es spaghetti aber
freut euch nicht zu früh denn ihr seid
die spaghetti jetzt gerade sitzt hier
irgendwo auf der oberfläche der erde und
seht dieses video und nur der
gravitationskraft der erde habt ihr es
zu verdanken dass sie nicht einfach weg
schwebt die gravitation zieht euch an
aber nicht alles von euch wird gleich
stark angezogen euer kopf ist
wahrscheinlich gerade am weitesten vom
erdkern entfernt und er fährt somit
minimal weniger anziehungskraft als eure
füße nun hier auf der erde ist das auch
kein problem der eure körpergröße
proportional zu entfernung zum erdkern
verschwindend gering ist aber bei einem
schwarzen loch das für seine masse viel
kleiner ist sie das schon ganz anders
aus dort erfahren eure füße irgendwann
wesentlich mehr gravitation als euer
kopf eure füße wollen schneller nach
unten als der rest ihres körpers dieser
kräfte unterschied wird stärker je näher
wir an den mittelpunkt des schwarzen
lochs kommen eure beine werden immer
länger und euer ganzer körper wird
gedehnt bis wir irgendwann so lang und
dünn seit wie eine spaghetti aber die
gravitation zieht weiter unterschiedlich
stark an euch bis schließlich euro
moleküle einzeln auseinandergerissen
werden
der offizielle wissenschaftliche begriff
für dieses phänomen ist spaghetti
sierung manchmal haben wissenschaftler
auch einen echt sehr dunklen humor und
was kommt jetzt
nun das ist eine der größten fragen
unserer zeit
die singularität wäre eine zu einfache
antwort denn was das genau heißt weiß
eigentlich keiner im inneren eines
schwarzen lochs brechen die gesetze der
physik zusammen
nichts geht mehr
kein raum keine zeit es ist ein loch in
unserer raumzeit
es existiert in diesem sinne gar nicht
das ist auch die antwort auf die frage
ist ein schwarzes loch unendlich dicht
man könnte genauso gut fragen ob grün
eine primzahl ist es ist nicht definiert
was erhält man wenn man durch 0 teilt je
nachdem wen man fragt unendlich und
vielleicht stimmt das auch vielleicht
ist ein schwarzes loch unendlich sticht
aber die brutale wahrheit ist wir wissen
es einfach nicht und ich glaube das ist
einer der grössten gründe warum wir alle
schwarze löcher so super spannend finden
sie feuern weiterhin unsere business
durst an und lassen uns unglaublich viel
über unser universum lernen und ich habe
noch nicht einmal über geladene oder
sich der edle schwarze löcher geredet
oder über hawking strahlung das
informations paradoxon wenn wir dahin
kommen dann wird es wirklich
kopfzerbrechen
wow das war ein super kompliziertes
thema ich habe mega lang gebraucht um
alles zu recherchieren
ich hoffe ich konnte euch schwarze
löcher zumindest ein bisschen besser
erklären
wenn euch diese art von videos
interessieren dann lass mir doch bitte
einen leichter damit ich weiß auf
weltraum videos und space und so ob das
alles bei euch gut ankommt auf ihr mehr
davon sehen wollt und wenn ihr noch mehr
fragen habt über schwarze löcher dann
stellt sie mir gerne unten in den
kommentaren und ansonsten verabschiede
ich mich von euch bis nächste woche
donnerstag